[Music]
in meant to be news mentos submitted by
average jus million Jamali and you gotta
say that Joe Mallya Jamali Ambro from
alia a pregnant women offered a stranger
on a plane the chance to adopt her baby
why why nots crazy that's crazy
your injury you know what I would do
what I would say to the lady I said I
wouldn't adopt it but can I have it
they're two different things why was it
different well he adopted to fill out
paperwork you know you have to get it
like you know you know you have to treat
it right but having it there's no
paperwork there's no paper trail just
give it to me yes one area versus the
other what what I mean you're a creep
and one snare no I'm not a creep I
didn't say I was gonna do something
nasty I didn't say that either but the
perception is why wouldn't you claim
this child as your own it's like you're
obviously gonna do something crazy with
it no you're not yeah but he's gonna I
mean this baby's gonna work when his
younger what little factory child labor
downstairs you could still do it legal
what do you make what do you make that
you need to be making shoes you don't
make thank you my baby isn't gonna and
I'll make one shoe at a time you'll be
work hard good point thank you so much
I'm not gonna do anything sexual or
weird what debate I didn't say that
right and then I'll and he'll also check
this out my baby's gonna get 50% that's
a lot you're pretty generous Oh
50% I would you get 50% if he's doing
all the work because it's my factory
yeah in the clients it's my factory I
set up the thing you work for me I'm
give you 50% what boss gives your kid
50% of the revenue joseph kony exactly I
don't know what that means but exactly
like kony2012 isn't the child soldier
yeah and my kid will be bothered Baker's
have been it
anyway this doesn't wanna be a big girl
and had to be hot than to be weird ah
come on you were doing so good well you
didn't even finish your sentence boy you
don't know where I was going I will give
her an education to go to private school
yup see thinking what do you tell
neighbor yeah yeah you catch up to come
you can't jump to conclusions with Bobby
I think it's safe to jump - no it's
definitely nothing you can't fish two
sentences because if you can didn't you
need to be thrown in jail cuz that's
disgusting so would it what happened
what happened alright
so Samantha was 24 years old when she
was eight months pregnant she was
fleeing an abusive relationship she was
heading to North Carolina from Arkansas
she missed the connecting flight in
Atlanta so but her missing that flight
they put her on this other flight and
that's where she met temple and temple
was originally booked on a later flight
so this was like totally by chance that
they even got to sit next to each other
in this flight because originally they
weren't supposed to be on this flight so
I was like a romp ah yeah and then so
Samantha was saying that when she met
temple at temple was just so excited for
her to be pregnant she's I call my gosh
you're pregnant but she doesn't know the
backstory
that's a pregnancy from abuse yeah could
a name is temple a strippers name
Brandon oh nevermind whose temple
grandin she's the one who came up with
the humane laws for cow slaughter oh the
lady with autism
sabirah wait what is it Sivan she's a
savant yeah she British she only reckons
she only ate jello there's a biopic
about her oh yeah yeah Claire Danes
played her yeah right I think so I don't
know she just where to checkered shirt I
don't know if I could get fall off each
other yeah so this flight was only one
hour so in this one hour they got to
know each other and that's when Samantha
offered like well you know I'm actually
trying to look for someone to adopt my
baby and then that's when they found out
that or Samantha found out that temple
was trying to adopt a baby as well what
a coinkidink
and it turned out that that's what
happened they ended up she ended up
adopting her be Bow Wow
it actually went down this is Samantha
this is temple why they look like
sisters already yeah she looks like she
could be her mom or something
Samantha's young yeah how old is
Samantha 24 right and she is older I
don't know her age but yeah she looks 40
so Samantha got beat up in stuff yeah
she was she just wasn't ready for this
baby he just forced upcoming inside her
I don't know how like the extent of her
abusive relationship cuz obviously she
doesn't want his baby so she's like [ __ ]
that [ __ ] I got so much more partying
years to go maybe maybe that was her
reasoning but why should I have a
question this is them with the best you
know the baby's way so is that uh did
she go through with the adoption she got
the baby yeah so then when Samantha was
in labor she called temple and temple
like flew over to where she was and was
there for the birth and everything and
yeah she adopted the baby boy that's
great McCall cute that guy that's so
cool
I'm just painting her to be an
irresponsible mom but that's awesome
yeah and then like which this part to me
is a little odd but apparently Samantha
moved to be closer to Temple and the kid
where I'm thinking like I mean I get it
I guess I think you want to be closer to
the kid but you give him up for adoption
but he's still one of you may be she was
just she felt like she was an unfit
mother yeah maybe that's complicated she
wanted to be in the baby's life still
but like not have the responsibility way
and still get a little bit weird that's
weird make a decision what if she has a
connection but just isn't financially
able yeah that might be the case because
I feel like what her decision was the
best decision um because she obviously
felt like and looking at her decisions
she's just not up for being a good mom
and now this kid has a chance I know but
it's still kind of where it's like I'm
not fit to be a mom but I still want to
be I mean I can see your point of view
but I still want to be involved but it's
also like someone that just hasn't
really figured [ __ ] out yet and they
kind of want to like buy a car but then
take it back and release it and then
like I don't know what I want to do yeah
it seems Shady lie
I want to see what if this one baby my
baby has a talent but all the sudden has
a violin right and that's my baby too
yeah yeah but there's paperwork involved
it protects the adoptive mother yeah
okay what do you say it in a nice way
you don't say you gonna say like I'm
dumb I was just throwing out an idea
I've still got an idea and then you have
to go work in law that's what Justin
Bieber's dad did that's what I'm saying
it's like Kelly Clarkson wrote a song
about her dad and you know he which she
maybe he tried to get back into her
alive right it's basically I'm saying a
lot of these people do that
so what I'm saying isn't it isn't a bad
thing if you gonna leave just leaf yeah
yeah if you're gonna leave Leave your
real home oh yeah do a [ __ ] magic
trick and [ __ ] go like that or you
know like I knew a guy I think we all
know this guy his mom didn't have a
husband
he laughed it was in the baby's life and
grandparents helped raise this kid and
this kid went to law school
miss Kim became president United States
his name is Obama yeah yeah I mean so
what I'm saying is that what I
understand the book she should have kept
the baby is what I'm saying right
Samantha Oh Samantha Samantha I do
whatever you kind of make it work yeah I
mean it's like you know I used but have
the baby be a good mother you know and
try to work it out yeah you don't give
it away or if you give it away than just
like Joe say move on with their life
that's like saying Steve Jobs for
example that's like saying if the if the
unfit mom were to have kept him would he
have received the education and all the
things that propelled him into being
Steve Jobs had he stayed with the entred
on fine financially restrained mother
thanks for doing that now we have Apple
that's you know what let me see maybe if
he would have stayed with his original
parents you want a gun cancer
oh my god that's also possibility of
exposure to some other thing I don't
know you know I mean what my point is is
that you know we don't know the other
side of Steve Jobs maybe he would have
made it better maybe it would have made
like pear watermelon yeah watermelon
better as a parent product a bigger
thing instead of like a iPads we have
jetpacks so basically you're just saying
people you don't know friends that's all
doing the best we can
yeah so it's not right to keep or leave
yeah I don't know we don't know that's
the best she crater it's a gamble and
who knows this adoptive parent could be
the shittiest mom ever yeah I mean not
that not that she's a shitty mom but she
was declined many times by adopting
adoption agencies because she was a
divorcee and like what else they might
have uncovered you know what it's God's
will I think this is a case of God's
will
Louis and I was it was destiny that
these two set together on the plane